several migrants connected to the
Beatdown of multiple New York City
police officers were just arrested in
Phoenix Arizona they're found at a
Greyhound bus station after leaving New
York where they were freed without bail
Tom fely is a former director of New
York ice removals and Tom joins me now
so now brag will finally present charges
to the grand jury with regard to these
folks all it took was a CrossCountry
Escape for him to do so
Tom good morning Todd yeah I was
listening to the DA speak the other day
and he was like you know the reason I
didn't ask for bail is because I didn't
have enough evidence unless me and you
are missing something we're both looking
at a video right now that that portrays
this whole event what's so fascinating
to me about what you just said and what
brag said it shows an underlying lack of
understanding as to what baale is there
for baale is there to keep people from
fleeing here you have people that are
extremely mobile who just did something
and fled that scene
why doesn't Alvin BR think that they
will then flee
again you know he must have took
different law classes because you you
just hit a key Point bail is meant to
keep the defendant there and not fleeing
it doesn't say anything about whether
you have enough evidence or if your case
is solid or all these other things he
keeps pointing to obviously bail reform
is a problem in New York state but even
the governor said that this charge
clearly is a bailable offense and bail
should have been applied Kathy hokel the
governor has been okay on this but I
would argue the reason we're in this
problem in the first place is just an
overall lack of understanding from our
elected leaders here's what Eric Adams
had to say about the case
listen while these five individuals were
are migrants I want to reiterate uh the
overwhelming number of 170 plus thousand
migrant and Asylum Seekers are attempted
to continue their next leg of their
journey of pursuing the American dream
Tom he just doesn't get it can we ever
truly solve this crisis if Democrat
leaders like Eric Adams and Democrat
leaders across the country fail to
distinguish between legal immigration
and illegal
immigration right and the legal term is
found in 8 USC and 8fr as a legal alien
listen New York can solve this problem
today all they have to do is stop being
a sanctuary City take is's lawful
detainer that's issued with a lawful
administrative warrant and a lawful
administrative order of removal and get
rid of this horrible green light law
that New York state has that prohibits
New York State working with ice ice
officers you know I think Adams was
saying you know we're not prohibiting
ice from doing their job yes yes you are
we can't run license plates we can't run
criminal histories we can't do all the
investigative things that we need to do
to keep New York State because of this
green light law and the governor she can
take care of this today those three
things you get rid of that New York
State's a great place again finally
shocking video showing a woman being
dragged along a Brooklyn Street by
migrants and they're part of an actual
gang linked to dozens of attacks they
mobilized this gang pretty darn quickly
running rampant through the streets of
New York as far back as November of last
year racking up 62 Grand Larsen and
dozens of attacks Tom no respect for our
laws and no fear of any consequences
final thought to
you listen if illegal aliens are going
to outright attack and assault our
police officers if they have no respect
for that they can give two craps about
you and I Todd that that's just the
reality they don't care about the rule
of law New York State and the governor
and the mayor of New York are are trying
to turn the other way but New York is
not safe anymore and eventually people
are going to wake up to the fact that
that that's the reality we're not safe
there's too many legal aliens here we
need to close the border Institute all
the policies that Trump had that Biden
took away on day one and the country
will be better we don't need a new bill
we just need to enforce the law Tom fely
thank you for your thoughts this morning
we appreciate it